[Music]
my name is eddie mexion co-founder and
owner of known as empanadas we're
located in beverly hills and west
hollywood in los angeles california well
known as empanadas is a combination of
several things in the front we have a
beautiful quick service restaurant but
we bake and serve over 30 flavors of
empanadas any given time and in the back
is a full production kitchen we have
many types of flavors with meat
vegetable cheese even dessert whatever
you're craving known as has an empanada
for you empanada comes from the spanish
verb empanada which means to cover in
dough or pastry so an empanada is
essentially any filling covered in dough
some of our most popular empanadas have
always been the beef and veggie our
signature beef filling starts by
sauteing onions then we add ground beef
once the beef is cooked we remove the
fat
add butter and mix it in we then add our
blend of spices which is made up of salt
black pepper oregano paprika and red
peppers once everything is mixed we let
it rest for a few minutes spread it on a
sheet pan you send it to the blast
chiller to cool down
once the filling is cool we mix in green
onions green olives hard boiled eggs we
then mix everything together again and
that's how we make our signature beef
filling
to make our classic veggie filling we
start by cooking spinach diced carrots
and broccoli while those are cooling we
saute garlic and onions with a blend of
spices and send that to chill
once our veggies are cooled we chop up
the spinach the broccoli we mix it in
with the garlic and onions and the diced
carrots and we mix in green peas
corn red peppers feta and parmesan
cheese we then mix all the ingredients
together by hand and that's our classic
veggie filling
and finally it's time to make the
empanadas when we first started we made
the empanadas by hand by folding the
edge we had different folding techniques
depending on the flavor of empanada that
was the original way to distinguish what
you were eating as the business grew it
was difficult to keep up with demand so
we then moved to using custom hand
operated empanada molds to close the
empanadas but even the hand press wasn't
efficient enough in the past year we've
averaged 15 to 20 000 empanadas a week
so we imported a custom empanada folding
machine from argentina
[Music]
it takes three people to operate the
machine one person places the dough into
the mold another person puts the filling
into the mold the machine then closes
the empanada and then feeds the finished
empanada to the end of the line where
the third person puts it on a tray each
tray holds about 40 empanadas when the
machine is operating at full speed it
can make 1 700 empanadas an hour once
the tray is complete we send it off to
cool and store overnight so they're
ready to bake serve and enjoy the next
day
every empanada is branded with our logo
and flavor so you know what you're about
to enjoy when you come to nona's you're
hit by this wonderful smell of freshly
baked empanadas you then see this
beautiful bright display case full of
empanadas with more flavors than you can
imagine there is no one perfect empanada
but what makes the empanada perfect is
the unlimited flavor combinations it's
portable it's handy you can enjoy it
anywhere anytime it really is the
perfect finger food
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you